ow you look fantastic oh thank you very
much you know what uh today i was
looking over and because we're talking
about chicago but i was looking over all
the all the films that you've done in
the past and we're looking over all the
different credits and one stuck out
which is jingle all the way you're in
the movie jingle all the way and we have
it sticks out in my mind because we have
a little arnold character that comes on
and he's constantly plugging jingle all
the way
all these years later and so it stuck
out and i was curious like you worked
with arnold in that classic film tell us
about that what was it like
well you know it's right up there with
the wizard of oz or mary poppins yeah
you know what's the other one the
wonderful life sure yeah christmas
classic yeah
it's one of those movies that i did it
and i i was
trying to talk to the director about the
reality of the character and i thought
so let me get this straight because
there's a scene at the end it's kind of
hard to it's hard to buy the scene at
the end it's hard to buy this scene and
and it's this that the character my
character is looking at her husband
who's in the turbo man costume right and
it's red but half of his face is showing
uh he happens to be talking like this
right but i don't recognize that it's my
husband
yeah yeah you're okay you're married
it's funny it's great this is a great
team where you're married to arnold
schwarzenegger and then at the end of
the movie it's just him wearing kind of
a mask up here and saying that's right
little boy i'll help you do this thing
and then you were just talking to him
like yeah and then he takes off the top
of the and you're like oh my god it's my
husband like i have no idea yeah
yeah and then it's like really sad
because the clip is sort of like
howard
howard
like i like the red costume it's kinky
what is wrong with that it's a sexy suit
i bought it uh
i'm really into arnold uh
but he must be he must have been a fun
guy to work with anyway great guy love
him he's a blast my favorite governor my
favorite arnold story ever is my this is
a true story my wife and i went on our
honeymoon and we're at this like little
resort uh in mexico and like 10 minutes
after we get there we're just sitting by
the pool arnold shows up and he's with
his little kids and his kids are doing
all the stuff that that that kids do
around their parents are like jumping in
the pool and making noise and arnold
just running around with a little basket
of pool toys no stop it no you stop it
over there cut it out quit it you guys
stop it
it was just great to see him reduced
completely reduced to like out of
control i'm used to seeing him blowing
people away now it's like i can't stop
these little kids
i don't know if i told you this story
before but there was our kids went to
the same preschool together for a while
and uh he was he was outside and i was
looking at him from afar and i was like
how sweet is he he was talking to his
child in the car and i just thought
that's so lovely and finally after a few
minutes they came out and i said what
kind of conversation we're talking
three-year-olds what were you saying to
your children they were in the car and
so happy and
i was teaching them how to talk to 10 in
how to say to uh
what is that i can't even say it i was
asking them how to count to ten in
german so you could see them like going
einstein
it's like daddy i don't know
you will count to ten now nines fine
streets and shrouds these houses
he's intense what a dad he would be uh i
have to ask you about this you did
something recently and i i i envy you
you you spent some time in france
which and and you got to write about it
yes was it for harper's it was for
harper's bazaar i did a little um
article it was about being spending the
summer in france and if you're spending
a long period of time there you sort of
go okay i'm going to be really cool i'm
going to go to france and pretend i'm
french
and i totally failed miserably like i
thought i was gonna look like a
friendship you thought you could blend
in and be a friendship yeah but i can't
i can't even even the way french women
stand is cool like they should just
stand there like this like
right right and you're kind of like they
could do even the most obnoxious thing
like burp and it would still look cool
like
yes i would like a croissant
[Laughter]
it's like it works sexy they're making
everything sexy yeah everything yeah
i've always wanted to live in a you know
when i get a vacation on this show it's
always like a couple of days it's never
long enough to sort of lose yourself in
the culture you could probably just
almost sort of think that you're a
french person if you were there for for
long enough
yeah that was the idea but i just failed
at it miserably i was like jeans and
tennis shoes and you know tried to look
really cool and right right it just
wasn't happening